this is so massive everyone's been
talking about this reboot and we've been
so excited so first of all I know you've
been working hard today but have you
gotten a chance to get out into the
comic-con craziness I have not we've
been getting we got to see like I saw a
few more it's awesome do you have any
time off this weekend to go and see
everyone yeah I have saturd most upset
pockets here and there I can hopefully
go and I think Saturday will be off so
yeah you'll be on the floor I'm sure in
a full mask and no one will recognize
you you'll be free I love that so listen
you had to be a little nervous when you
got this job because there's already a
built-in fan base they are expecting
things from you there's a lot of
expectation on the show so how are you
feeling I think after today like really
good yeah yeah it kind of just made
everything like the excitement level and
to actually get a response you know
there's there's actually something for
people to have seen now we add the pilot
yeah it just it's been really positive
and I feel I feel really happy and
grateful I know like it W felt surreal
so surreal
sitting in front of all these people who
are like loved the show so much and but
it was so warm and they were so
welcoming and we feel so grateful to be
taking on this role in the repo business
there's always people they're like oh my
god I love that show I'm so excited and
then there's people that are skeptical
like you can do it as well as the first
one ever
yeah what do you say to those people I
think there will always be those people
and that's just like tuning out like
what you want to don't want to hear and
what you pay attention what you do want
to do yeah I just see today though on
Twitter after we did the the pilot that
somebody said it's because may not we're
not in competition you know it's very
much intact and yeah I'm beloved but
they said it's a really nice tribute
great yes and if they see it like that
yeah I think there's a lot of negativity
but there's also a lot of positivity
yeah well I don't like focus on that
yeah nothing like what's the point of
doing what we do you know we converted
I've seen accounts that previously we're
like Oh
rebo yeah okay yeah now is that possibly
one of your powers because everyone's of
course now like what are the power my
character's powers telekinesis which is
cool really cool I like doing that yeah
I'm Irene Ines what am I thinking right
now that your outfits great obviously
which is ice up time so when you got
those do you found out that those were
gonna be your powers were you like yes
this is good because this feels like
something I would want or were you like
I would never want that yeah I mean like
it was really cool because the way Jenny
explained the power is that like Noah's
like a control freak so when she stops
time she has conversations with people
yeah I shall see all the things that she
won't say in real time so I was like oh
what an interesting way to like control
your relationship with people and like
change the outcome and I never thought
of it that way
it's amazing so how did you guys bond
yeah I'll get the job and then your
sisters on the show ish and so you know
how did you become a trio well we went
and ate together yes we broke bread yeah
yes yeah I think we were all really
excited a little bit nervous and just
sort of open to it and open to each
other and Soph
yeah I usually thought if we support
each other and just be though
yeah like the casting people and Jenny
and Jessica and Amy did a really good
job because we're all very different
like energy wise and so it's like the
best energy soup yes
[Music]
yeah we're like very different but it's
all very complementary okay so wait tell
me about each of you like what are you
like I'm the a type super like we don't
have a person of my friends so like what
are what are you
who's the latest to get to say okay so
you're actually the same cool
professional okay I don't know I feel
like back yeah I think you're quite calm
I'm very calm yeah I always say like I'm
like the best in like a if like havoc
happens I'm like you just come to me
comic-con
or just like the idea I'd be like
nervous laughter hang in the corner any
chance to to speak or interact with the
original cast of charmed wish them have
been like active on Twitter and like
I've been giving games you know she's
like flag goes flying and I'm good is
there any possibility that at some point
one hour two or three of them could pop
in and I would love it for them - yeah
yeah I just think that will be so cool I
think you kind of lose their minds
yeah like to figure out a way to do the
multiverse yeah be so possible and like
welcomed okay I love that now listen
this shows not only about the acting
there's a lot of focus on the fashion
because we were all trying to be back in
the day Rose McGowan when her choker is
a tank top
yes I asked our costume designer has
like can I have her boots I would have
put like awesome way to bring back a
little bit of fashion she has--she like
these high platform boots always amazing
and so how important and how fun has the
fashion been on the show Wow I'll start
the low my character because she doesn't
know these people yet she I'm pretty
much in the same outfit for the whole of
the pilot
you know from episode 2 onwards that
Macy will get you know a more expansive
wardrobe yeah I think we're Godspeed
yeah our wardrobe designer costume
designer Mandy line who did like pretty
low liars and a lot of very cool stuff
yeah is I met her I ran into her yoga
class in Vancouver of all places and she
was just so cool and had her stuff
figure it out and was like caring about
the characters and what they hired
that's so she's excited it really just
like specific to like very like Mel's
like very passionate and driven so I
think her palate is gonna like like that
I'm fun so I have a I wanna see my power
I can't wait to find out your palette
have you stolen anything from set yet
yes just like why we steal my songs if I
need it
oh well just a saw no but like also a
ring oh okay but I didn't do it on
purpose this time
yeah I want to remember nah you just in
your pocket yeah yeah that's that I can
I can fit okay should do at least you
didn't take that t-shirt you wore for
like you know no I'd see it seemed quite
love okay if you guys had to have you
know a power that was not your power on
the show in real life what's your which
Lea power that you want I like to fly
that'd be really awesome okay so I need
be so cool um I don't know I just like I
just want to be an re possible even if I
keep talking like a spell do like
Almonte magic okay let's do magic
genetics okay I really like the power to
know all of the languages in the world
then you could go anything you could go
to you know
place in the Amazon I'm be able to still
communicate think I'm really amazing I
love that so much okay so here the last
thing I was just thinking it is the 20th
anniversary of this series ever starting
so I just think it would be really cute
if you looked in the camera and just
said like happy 20th anniversary - okay
are you ready this camera right Edie's
timer here okay ready three two one
happy 20th anniversary charms
we're live do it one more time
ready three please - happy 20th
anniversary charms but it's so cute okay
come over to the photobooth we're gonna
have some fun
so this is fun Photo Booth over here you
get to choose we have Wonder Woman